mm 19's only a couple months old we
haven't given it a name yet so how about
the year of the woke billionaire sit
back and watch is the Democratic
presidential candidates simultaneously
jockey to establish the most left-wing
possible credentials and at the very
same time feverishly suck up to the
super-rich to fund their campaigns we've
seen a lot some of this before Tom
Steyer and George Soros those are the
obvious examples but there are many many
many more on Saturday just this past
Saturday coming Saturday rather senator
Cory Booker is attending a Silicon
Valley fundraiser hosted by Gary and
Laura Lauder their heirs to the 14
billion dollar Estee Lauder fortune
Pamela Harris has had a fundraiser in
Beverly Hills that was attended by an
army of wealthy studio execs Kirsten
Gillibrand didn't even start her
campaign for president before asking the
permission of Wall Street so what's the
message
rich people are highly progressive now
and you can see why they love mass
immigration it brings them servants they
support federally-mandated snobbery
masquerading as environmentalism
abortion is essentially a sacrament to
them especially when practiced in poor
neighborhoods but here's the confusing
part these are by definition affluent
people and yet increasingly confiscatory
tax rates are a rallying cry for the
Democratic Party so why are billionaires
so eager to back candidates who want to
seize their assets to fund new
entitlements this is confusing here's
one reason billionaires understand that
they will never have to pay those taxes
why because the top federal income tax
rate stops at about 500 grand
so what's difference between someone
making $500,000 a year and someone
making 50 million dollars a year the
answer the richer one can much more
easily evade paying full freight and
they do this group makes far more of
their money on capital gains which are
tax they're only half the rate of your
salary and some of its not even taxed at
all under the 2017 tax law investments
in federally designated opportunity
zones evade capital gains taxes entirely
one such opportunity zone by the way is
right by the army-navy Country Club in
Arlington Virginia
one of America's richest zip codes but
even on their official tax returns even
on income the richest Americans are
paying less according to the IRS the top
1% of Americans pay about 27 percent of
our income in taxes but the top tenth of
one percent that's people who make 35
million a year pay less than 26 percent
and the top thousandth of a percent the
absolute richest pay less than 24
percent in other words past a certain
point the richer you are the less you
pay
that's why billionaires back socialism
it doesn't cost them much Dana Perino
hosts the daily briefing what Dana
Perino
she's also coming on later in the show
on final exam with Greg Gutfeld but for
now I'm rooting for you as you know
don't tell him there is this really
interesting dynamic where the party the
Democratic Party is becoming openly
socialist in some cases but certainly
embracing economic populism but it's
still funded by the richest segment of
our society how does that work it is
pretty interesting and actually to have
Bernie Sanders launch his campaign in
the week after the basically another
fellow Democratic Socialist chased
Amazon out of New York City it put
Bernie Sanders to the left of mérida
Blasio and Governor Cuomo it's not do
that in some ways I feel like Bernie has
been a victim of his own success
he has won this war without even firing
a shot in 2016 he basically said this is
what I'm going to be for he ran
unabashedly on it and he had a lot of
support and I think if the Democrats
hadn't rigged their primary he might
have actually been the nominee perhaps
good for him that he wasn't because then
he had time to let these ideas percolate
do you think there would be in
Alexandria Ocasio Cortez in 2020 if
there are 2019 if there had not been a
Bernie Sanders and no it's a good point
absolutely not and also the other thing
you have is you have Democratic
candidates like Kamala Harris and
Elizabeth Warren both taking great pains
this week to say that they are not
socialists they are capitalists and they
have to explain it but you have to ask
yourself is it a distinction without a
difference if you are talking about free
healthcare for all free college for all
unabashedly bashing
the financial institutions and promising
lots of things that are going to look
like a socialist country that is why the
Democrats find themselves already in
February of 2019 on the losing end of a
debate with Donald Trump
are they we're almost out of time but
I'm just interested since you're steeped
in the numbers are they going to lose
that debate I mean they'll lose it as
far as I'm concerned but is the public
on the side of capitalism or socialism
since your question well I actually
think that Karl Rove has talked about
this for a while and he's right if
younger people in America say that they
more aligned with socialism we should
take them seriously this this week
Tucker we found that most people in
America could not pass a basic
citizenship test that immigrants have to
take in order to get a chance to live
here in America so we have a lot of
making up to do but I do think that the
country is still a center-right country
but conservatives capitalists people who
do not want socialism have to try to
make a very good case for it because
Bernie Sanders has a grassroots
organization across the country willing
to send him $25 over and over and over
again that makes a big difference
they're not just going to big donors and
billionaires to get funding even though
they do that too they have support all
across the country and people should
take that very seriously
they should take it I I couldn't agree
more reason people feel that way
dana perino it's great to see you as
always we're gonna see you in just a
minute okay